HEY, SHAWNA.
>> Sean: THAT WAS A GREAT
MESSAGE WITH THE CARDINAL,
GOOD JOB.
TUCKER, GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
MAJOR COVERAGE OF OUR PROGRESS
AT COVID-19, FACTS WITHOUT FEAR.
IF THE CURRENT PATTERN HOLDS,
CORONAVIRUS COULD BE LEVELING
OFF AS WE SPEAK AND FOLLOWED BY
DRAMATIC DECLINE IF THE MODELS
HOLD.
ONE FREQUENTLY CITED MODEL WHICH
PREDICTED A DEATH TOLL, AND THAT
WAS WITHOUT ANY TRAVEL BAN WERE
QUARANTINES OR MITIGATION WOULD
HAVE BEEN 2.2 MILLION, AS HIGH
AS 2.2 MILLION AMERICANS DYING.
THEN WE HAD THE BIG SIGNS TEN
DAYS AGO, 240,000.
THAT WAS REVISED DOWN TO 81,002
DAYS AGO AND IT HAS BEEN REVISED
DOWNWARD AGAIN TO 60,000.
ONE QUESTION WE DO ALL NEED TO
ASK TONIGHT IS HOW THESE NUMBERS
HAVE BEEN SO FAR OFF THE MARK
AND HOW DO WE SAFELY OPEN UP
THIS COUNTRY AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE?
WE HAVE A LOT OF IDEAS AND WE
WILL ALSO BALANCE THE MEDICAL
SIDE OF THIS WITH DR. OZ VERSUS
THE ECONOMIC SIDE AND GETTING
OUR LIVES BACK TO NORMAL.
THE NUMBER OF PREDICTED
HOSPITALIZATIONS FELL FROM
140,000, 290,000.
THAT SAME MODEL IS PREDICTING
THE PEAK IS JUST THREE DAYS
AWAY.
MEANWHILE THE EPICENTER IN
NEW YORK STATE, NEW
HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE ROUGHLY
HALF OF WHAT THEY WERE A WEEK
AGO AND, IN FOUR DAYS MORE
PATIENCE HAVE BEEN RELEASED THAN
HAVE BEEN ADMITTED.
KEEP IN MIND THE MODEL PREDICTED
THAT THE STATE WOULD NEED 70,000
HOSPITAL BEDS, OVER 12,000 ICU
BEDS AT THIS POINT.
INSTEAD, NEW YORK HAS ONLY
NEEDED 16,500 BEDS AND JUST OVER
4,000 ICU BEDS AND ABOUT AT
THIRD OF THE PREDICTED NEED.
IN THE STATE OF NEW JERSEY ONLY
THREE OF THE STATE 72 HOSPITALS
ARE AT CAPACITY IN THOSE STATES
HAVE EXPERIENCED A SURGE
ANYWHERE NEAR WHAT WAS TOLD AND
EXPECTED.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
SHIPPED OUT OVER 11 MILLION
LETTER AND UNDERN95MASK, AND VEN
AS NEEDED WITH 2,000 MORE BEING
AVAILABLE MONDAY.
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO FIGHT
COVID-19 THIS COUNTRY MUST ALSO
HARNESS ITS INGENUITY AND
BRILLIANCE, THE FREE MARKET
SYSTEM, AND FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
GET AMERICAN SAFELY BACK TO WORK
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE, WHERE THEY
WANT TO BE.
YOU CAN’T ALLOW AMERICA’S
BUSINESSES TO WITHER ON THE VINE
AND DIE.
THERE ARE PARTS OF THIS COUNTRY
WITH VERY LOW INCIDENCE OF
COVID-19 THAT LIKELY, WE COULD
OPEN THOSE AREAS PROBABLY KNOW.
A GEOGRAPHICAL OPENING WILL BE A
NO-BRAINER BUT EVEN IN THESE
AREAS THERE WILL BE SOME CHANGES
MOVING FORWARD ESPECIALLY TO
AVOID A REBOUND.
THERE IS THE KEY.
WE HAVE TO OPEN UP THE ECONOMY
IN A WAY THAT PREVENTS FUTURE
OUTBREAKS AND IMMEDIATELY
CONTAINS THEM BUT ALSO PROTECTS
YOUR CIVIL LIBERTIES AND YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
ONE REALITY WE MUST ALL
UNDERSTAND AND ACCEPT.
ONE THING THAT WILL HAPPEN IS
YOU CAN’T SHUT DOWN THE COUNTRY
LIKE THIS AGAIN.
A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN THAT
BALANCES BOTH ASPECTS OF THIS
AND NEEDS TO BE IMPLANTED.
WE WILL BE THINKING OF NEW WAYS
AND NEW PARADIGMS JUST AS WE
HAVE THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE
PANDEMIC.
FOR EXAMPLE EMPLOYERS COULD
UTILIZE CONTACTLESS DIGITAL
THERMOMETERS.
REMEMBER I WENT TO THE NAVY
HOSPITAL SHIP, THE COMFORT?
THEY TOOK MY TEMPERATURE AND
DIDN’T TOUCH ME.
THE CONTRACTOR EMPLOYEES
TEMPERATURES AS THEY ENTER
BUILDINGS ESPECIALLY IN BIG
CITIES.
FACE MASKS, ELBOW BUMS THAT SET
OF HANDSHAKES AND TELECOMMUTE HE
COULD NOW BECOME A TEMPORARY NEW
NORMAL AND GET OUR BUSINESS UP
AND RUNNING.
SOCIAL DISTANCING ON SOME LEVEL
AS WELL.
ONE HUGE CHALLENGE WILL BE
RESTAURANTS AND BARS.
DO WE TAKE TEMPERATURES WHEN
PEOPLE ENTER A PLACE TO EAT?
DO YOU LIMIT THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ANY ONE RESTAURANT CAN
HAVE?
THAT WILL BE HARD BUT TESTING
WILL LIKELY BE THE KEY SOLUTION
TO ALL OF THIS.
WE COULD HAVE WIDESPREAD
DISTRIBUTION OF THESE NEWLY
APPROVED, NOT ONLY THE
ANTIBIOTIC TEST BUT THE
FIVE-MINUTE COVID-19 TEST
RESULTS.
YOU HAVE IT OR NOT HAVE IT.
THAT COULD PLAY A HUGE PART IN
OPENING UP THE COUNTRY ALL OVER
THE PLACE MORE QUICKLY AND MORE
SAFELY AND CONTRACT TRACING WILL
ALSO COME INTO PLAY.
HOW QUICKLY CAN THESE TESTING
METHODS TO BE AVAILABLE?
FOR EXAMPLE, CAN ABBOTT
MASS-PRODUCE THEIR TESTING.
THEY ARE DOING 50,000 PER DAY
NOW OR HAVE THE CAPABILITY.
ANOTHER FACTOR THAT COMES INTO
PLAY AS PATIENT PRIVACY.
YES, THAT MATTERS.
WE CANNOT VIOLATE THIS IN ANY
WAY.
THERE WILL BE NO DATABASE.
PEOPLE MUST BE ENSURING COMPLETE
PRIVACY AND COMPLETE ANONYMITY
AND ALL OF THIS.
ALSO, YOU WOULD THINK THAT THE
COOPERATION OF PEOPLE WOULD
FACTOR IN AS WELL.
NOW IF THE SHUTDOWN GOES ON FOR
MONTHS ON END AMERICA WILL NOT
BE THE AMERICA WE GREW UP IN.
VERY SPECIFIC CHALLENGES FOR
VERY SPECIFIC BUSINESSES.
MASSIVE CHALLENGES FOR BIG
CITIES LIKE NEW YORK CITY.
SMALL, MEDIUM AND LARGE
BUSINESSES WILL GO BELLY UP IF
WE ARE NOT CAREFUL AND NO AMOUNT
OF GOVERNMENT AID IS GOING TO
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM.
LIFELONG DREAMS WILL BE
SHUTTERED, LIVES WILL BE RUINED
AND THE HARDSHIP COULD UNDER
THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES GO ON FOR
YEARS.
FOR SOME REASON YOU GOT MANY
DOOMSDAY DEMOCRATS MEDIA MOB
PEOPLE AND HE COMPLETELY AND
TOTALLY IRRESPONSIBLE FROM
WHATEVER BACKGROUND, THEY WANT
THE SHUTDOWN SEEMLY TO CONTINUE
INDEFINITELY REGARDLESS OF FACTS
THAT ARE ON THE GROUND.
AND THEY CONSTITUTE AND CONTINUE
FOR AT LEAST ANOTHER 18 MONTHS.
IS HE OUT OF HIS MIND?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> REALISTICALLY COVID-19 WILL
BE HERE FOR THE NEXT 18 MONTHS
OR MORE.
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO RETURN TO
NORMALCY UNTIL WE FIND A VACCINE
OR EFFECTIVE MEDICATIONS.
I KNOW THAT’S DREADFUL NEWS TO
HEAR.
AND THAT COULD GO INTO THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS IF NOT A
MILLION.
WE CANNOT RETURN TO NORMAL UNTIL
THERE’S A VACCINE.
>> Sean: THE EARLIEST AS 15-18
MONTHS.
REALLY?
BECAUSE THAT LUNATIC IS ADVISING
THE JOE BIDEN CAMPAIGN.
WHAT HE’S SUGGESTING, THAT WOULD
DESTROY THE ENTIRE ECONOMY.
ASK YOURSELF, 18 18 STRAIGHT
MONTHS.
MR. EMANUEL IS FAR FROM THE
DEMOCRAT SEEMLY ROOTING FOR WHAT
IT WOULD BE A LONG-TERM ECONOMIC
CATASTROPHE.
THE NEW YORK GOVERNOR, THE EVER
INCOMPETENT ALL TALK AND NO
ACTION ANDREW CUOMO JUST
PROMISING NEW YORK BUT MICHAEL
BACK TO NORMAL ANYTIME SOON.
WELL, THERE IS AN AMBITIOUS
PLAN.
SO DOES HE THINK A MONTHS LONG
SHUTDOWN FOR THE AMERICA’S
BIGGEST CITY IS GOING TO BE A
GOOD THING?
AND WHY DOES NOBODY IN THE MEDIA
MOB EVER HOLD THAT GUY ACCOUNT
TO ACCOUNTABLE?
NO STATE HAS HAD IT AS BAD AS
NEW YORK, WHERE WE ARE TONIGHT.
OF COURSE NEW YORK CITY IS THE
MOST DENSELY PACKED AREA OF THE
UNITED STATES AND WE KNOW IT’S
AN INTERNATIONAL CITY THAT HOSTS
TRAVELED FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
WORLD.
IT’S OBVIOUS THEY ARE MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO PANDEMICS.
ANDREW CUOMO KNEW THIS, AND THEY
ARE BOTH COMPLETELY UNPREPARED
TO FAIL IN ANY WAY.
IN THE NEW REPORT, THE FORMER
CDC CHIEF FOUND THAT IF NEW YORK
HAD ACTED SOONER WITH THE
STAY-AT-HOME ORDER, THE DEATH
TOLL COULD HAVE BEEN REDUCED BY
A WHOPPING 50-80%.
IN MARCH, CONRAD de BLASIO WAS
TELLING NEW YORK CITY RESIDENTS
TO GO OUT AND ENJOY THE THEATER.
CUOMO WAS REASSURING HIS
CONSTITUENTS THAT THE RISK WAS
LOW.
ON MARCH 2ND, BUT WHERE THEY
SING ON FOX NEWS?
I WAS SAYING ASYMPTOMATIC PEOPLE
THAT ARE HIGHLY CONTAGIOUS IS
DANGEROUS.
I WAS SAYING THAT IN JANUARY AND
IT WAS SAYING IT BEFORE ANYBODY
ELSE BUT THIS IS A CUOMO
MARCH 2ND, NOT THAT LONG AGO.
A LITTLE OVER A MONTH.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> EXCUSE OUR ARROGANCE AS
NEW YORKERS.
WE THINK WE HAVE THE BEST
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM ON THE PLANET
RIGHT HERE IN NEW YORK.
SO WHEN YOU ARE SAYING WHAT
HAPPENED IN ANOTHER COUNTRY
VERSUS WHAT HAPPENED HERE, WE
DON’T EVEN THINK IT’S GOING TO
BE AS BAD AS IT WAS IN OTHER
COUNTRIES.
>> Sean: THAT WAS A LITTLE
OVER A MONTH AGO, RIGHT ANDREW?
WERE YOU THAT ARROGANT THAT YOU
FAILED TO PREPARE YOUR ESTATE OR
YOUR CITY?
DON’T FORGET, CUOMO WASN’T
WARRANTED DIRECTLY THAT
NEW YORK STATE WOULD BE 15,783
VENTILATOR SHORT.
THAT WAS NONE OF WHAT THE
TASK FORCE RECOMMENDED AND WE
HAVE A DUTY AND RESPONSIBILITY
TO DO THIS.
WE HAVE ANOTHER REPORT OF
ANOTHER WARNING FOR PROPUBLICA
WHICH IN 2006, THEY WERE ALSO
WARNED.
NEW YORK CITY’S PANDEMIC PLANNED
FOR THE CITY TO PURCHASE 5,500
NEW VENTILATORS OF THE TIME.
AND WHAT THEY DIDN’T MAINTAIN
THEM, BUT THEN SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
2014 AND 16, NOBODY REALLY
KNOWS, VENTILATORS WERE
AUCTIONED OFF TO SOME HIGHEST
BIDDER.
WE DON’T KNOW WHO.
DOES ANYONE IN THE MEDIA MOB
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
FAILURE?
EVERY PUBLIC OFFICIAL IN
NEW YORK, HAVE THEY EVER BEEN
HELD ACCOUNTABLE BECAUSE OF
DONALD TRUMP DIDN’T BUILD THE
BIGGEST HOSPITAL IN THE COUNTRY,
THEY SAVED AT THE NAVY HOSPITAL
SHIP AND FIVE OTHER HOSPITALS IN
NEW YORK AND SEND THE MASKS AND
RESPIRATORS ON THE VENTILATORS,
THEY WOULD HAVE HAD NOTHING.
AND HE’S ALSO STAFFING THE
BIGGEST HOSPITAL IN THE
JAVITS CENTER AND THEY ARE
TAKING COVID-19 PATIENTS BECAUSE
NEW YORK WASN’T PREPARED FOR
ANYTHING.
THE MOB IN THE MEDIA GET A PASS
EVERY SINGLE TIME.
>> WHAT ARE THE RISKS AND DOES
IT WORK?
THOSE ARE THE QUESTIONS THAT
NEED TO BE ANSWERED ABOUT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
IN THE DEBATE CONTINUES TO WAIT
RAGE IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP ASKED WHAT DO
YOU HAVE TO LOSE?
MEDICAL EXPERTS SAY, YOUR LIFE.
GOVERNOR CUOMO SAYS MONDAY HE
SEEN SOME PROMISING RESULTS IN
NEW YORK WHERE HOSPITALS ARE
ALLOWED TO USE
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH AZITHROMYCIN.
>> I LOVE HOW CUOMO WAS TALKING
ABOUT CABIN FEVER AND TRYING TO
HELP PEOPLE THROUGH THE THERAPY
PART OF THIS, THE PSYCHOLOGY OF
THE EXPERIENCE.
AND THAT IS A DISPLAY OF
FANTASTIC CRISIS MESSAGING.
>> THIS IS AN ADMINISTRATION
THAT ONLY ACTS IN ITS OWN SELF
INTEREST, AND THE GOVERNOR CUOMO
SHOWS WHAT A LEADER DOES WHEN HE
FOCUSES ON THE SAFETY OF THE
PEOPLE.
>> I HAVE TO ADMIT THAT I AM A
FAN OF ANDREW CUOMO AND WISH
VERY MUCH THAT HE WAS
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
NOW.
>> Sean: WAIT UNTIL AMERICA
SEES THE WAY HE SPENT
750 MILLION ON A FAILED SOLAR
PANEL PROJECT AND
PANEL PROJECT AND $600 MILLION
DEBACLE ON SOME COMPUTER CHIP
AND 90 MILLION ON SOME OTHER
LIGHT BULB DEAL IN CALIFORNIA?
ALL WASTED, PAUL MOTHBALLED.
YOU WOULD THINK ANY OF THESE
PEOPLE WOULD BE SO FORGIVING OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR NOT BUYING
16,000 VENTILATOR THAT HE WAS
WARNED TO BUY? NOW,
SOME ARE ROOTING FOR THE COUNTRY
TO STAY IN A CONSTANT STATE OF
LOCKDOWN WHICH MEANS FAILURE.
RENOWNED ECONOMIST’S ART LAFFER,
SMART GUY, ALWAYS RATED FOR THIS
COUNTRY TO SUCCEED.
AND NOW HE BELIEVES THE KEY TO
GETTING THE COUNTRY BACK ON
TRACK IS NOT ANOTHER MASSIVE NEW
BIG GOVERNMENT STIMULUS PLAN.
INSTEAD, HE’S ADVOCATING FOR THE
PAYROLL TAX CUT WHICH WOULD